ist die entstehung von leben auf der
erde ein einmaliger zufall oder führen
günstige bedingungen zwangsläufig zu
leben und intelligenz ein us
forschungsteam hat jetzt eine virtuelle
zeitreise gemacht um diese so
entscheidende frage endgültig zu klären
und manche fachleute glauben sogar dass
die aliens schon hier sind und andere
dass sie uns alle töten könnten das
neueste zur alien forschung jetzt den
klicks umsatz in future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks um
gibt es jetzt übrigens auch als podcast
die links zu spotify und apple podcasts
sind unten in der video beschreibung
fachleute weltweit beschäftigen sich
schon seit vielen jahren mit der frage
ob wir ihm alle nun alleine sind oder
nicht wie wahrscheinlich ist
außerirdisches leben wirklich die
theorie dass das leben auf unserer erde
tatsächlich nur durch einen einmaligen
zufall entstanden sein könnte wird immer
unwahrscheinlicher dennoch ist die frage
ob wir allein im universum sind immer
noch längst nicht endgültig geklärt und
das obwohl nicht nur mit hilfe von
teleskopen sondern auch mit raumsonden
und den antennen das seti projekt es
wirklich intensiv danach ausschau
gehalten wird doch der letzte kleine
schüssel fehlt der endgültige beweis
zumindest proben von außerirdischen
mikroben doch fest steht es gibt
zahlreiche indizien also quasi beweise
hinweise die eindeutig für die existenz
von außerirdischen lebens sprechen zb
auch die aktuelle studie des astronomen
david kipping von der columbia
university in new york er hat eine
virtuelle zeitreise gemacht und
untersucht inwieweit sich organismen
unter ähnlichen bedingungen entwickeln
die ausgangsfrage dabei ist unsere
evolution ein einmaliger zu fall und das
leben auf der erde eine seltene ausnahme
oder führen solche bedingungen fast
zwangsläufig zu leben und möglicherweise
sogar zu intelligentem leben konkret
untersuchten die fachleute mit hilfe
statistischer verfahren
inwieweit sich die irdische evolution
unter demselben ausgangsbedingungen
genauso noch einmal zugetragen hatte
das alles basiert auf den folgenden
grundgedanken auf der erde gab es
bereits vor 3,5 milliarden jahren erste
organismen
das legen micro fossilien möglicherweise
ist das leben auf der erde aber auch
schon vor vier milliarden jahren
entstanden
dafür sprechen einschlüsse von
kohlenstoff in so genannten zirkon
kristall wie auch immer dieser zeitpunkt
markiert den anfang des evolution
zeitfensters in dieser studie es endet
an dem punkt wo sich die sonne aufbläht
und es auf der erde viel zu heiß und
trocken für leben wird so spielten die
us wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler quasi die erdgeschichte
bei denselben ausgangsbedingungen in
dauerschleife ab mit hilfe von
statistischen berechnungen analysierten
die fachleute dann wie häufig und wann
genau sich einfaches und auch
intelligentes leben entwickelt das
forschungsteam schreibt dazu in der
aktuellen studie das schnelle auftauchen
erster lebensform und die er später
entwicklung des menschen scheinen auf
eine gesetzmäßigkeit hinzudeuten aber
mit dieser studie können wir das
quantifizieren
diese methode ist vergleichbar mit den
wahrscheinlichkeiten beim wetten
sie erlaubt ein wiederholtes testen
ausgehend von bestehenden daten im
prinzip ist es wie eine positive
rückkopplungsschleife die die schätzung
der wahrscheinlichkeit eines ereignisses
immer weiter verfeinert das ergebnis ist
überraschend eindeutig erdähnliche
bedingungen führen dazu dass sich
einfache organismen sehr schnell und
häufig entwickeln und dieses ergebnis
ist nach ansicht der fachleute auch auf
andere planeten übertragbar konkret
liegt die chance dass sich einfaches
leben sehr schnell unter ähnlichen
bedingungen entwickelt bei mindestens
drei zu eins wenn man davon ausgeht dass
die ersten lebensspuren bereits von vor
vier milliarden jahren stammen steigt
die wahrscheinlichkeit nach angaben der
us fachleute sogar auf neun zu eins
die chancen für intelligente
lebensformen dagegen stehen nur so 3 zu
2 also fast 50 50 zivilisationen und
kulturen entstehen demnach erst zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt der evolution nach
den ersten einzeln dauerte es
beispielsweise mehr als 3,7 milliarden
jahre bis die vormenschen entstand
die ersten hochkulturen gab es sogar
erst knapp vier milliarden jahre später
im klartext spricht also einiges dafür
dass planeten mit ähnlichen bedingungen
relativ schnell von einfachen organismen
bewohnt werden laut kipping könnte dies
schon in weit weniger als einer
milliarden jahre nach der jeweiligen
planetenentstehung der fall sein zitat
die wette auf ein universum voller leben
steht daher ganz gut intelligentes
extraterrestrisches leben dagegen
braucht mehr um sich zu entwickeln ein
planet muss ich dafür deutlich länger
stabil und lebensfreundlich präsentieren
und selbst unter diesen voraussetzungen
kann es laut der aktuellen studie
ausbleiben dass sich intelligentes leben
entwickelt dennoch ist der us-forscher
kipping optimistisch die suche nach
intelligentem leben anderswo im all
sollte sich daher auf keinen fall davon
entmutigen lassen
die frage nach der existenz von
außerirdischen leben war der
wissenschaftler frank drake bereits in
den 60er jahren auf die spur gegangen er
hatte eine formel entwickelt mit der
sich die wahrscheinlichkeit für
außerirdisches leben im all ausrechnen
lässt und zwar wie viele intelligente
zivilisationen in unserer milchstraße
existieren könnten
konkret enthält die drake gleichung
viele verschiedene faktoren in diesem
bereich also beispielsweise die anzahl
der planeten in der habitablen zone um
einen stern und die chance und das dort
leben entsteht so wie auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit wie intelligent ist
dann sein könnte
doch die meisten der dort gefragten
faktoren basieren lediglich auf
schätzungen
die konkreten zahlen fehlen und so
werden schätzwerte eingesetzt so dass
die drake gleichung sehr
unterschiedliche ergebnisse liefert
allerdings wissen wir heute viel mehr
eben durch solche studien und kennen die
anzahl an galaxien an sternensystem und
planeten viel genauer dazu der us
astronom sestak vom seti institute in
einem universum mit zwei millionen
galaxien wäre es ziemlich vermessen
anzunehmen dass nur die erde allein
intelligente kreaturen hervorgebracht
hat erst vor zwei jahren hat er unter
anderem auf basis der berühmten drake
gleichung abgeschätzt dass es alleine in
unserer milchstraße rund 10.000
außerirdische zivilisation geben könnte
von anderen galaxien ganz zu schweigen
das krasse dabei die nächste
außerirdische zivilisation könnte ich
sogar in unserer nachbarschaft in einem
umkreis
von 1000 bis 2000 lichtjahren befinden
vor unserer haustür ist das allerdings
nicht so ganz mit heutiger technik würde
es etwa 20 millionen jahre dauern um
eine solche welt zu erreichen vor allem
die jüngsten ergebnisse aus der
exoplanetenforschung machen große
hoffnungen darauf dass der große
durchbruch kurz bevor stehen vor allem
auf den sogenannten supererden ist leben
nach ansicht vieler fachleute mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit möglich als diese
entstanden sind könnten riesige mengen
an wasserstoff von ihrer mutter sterben
übrig geblieben sein
dieses befindet sich in der gashülle der
super erden und könnte bei der
regulierung der temperatur eine
entscheidende rolle spielen denn
wasserstoff ist ein noch größeres
treibhausgas als kohlendioxid somit
könnte die atmosphäre solcher super
irgendwann genug für flüssige ozeane
seien sogar fernab der jupiter bahn und
das könnte bedeuten dass organismen auf
solchen supererden quer durch die
galaxie reisen
denn selbst ein einzelner planet ohne
stern könnte dann wasser bei
ausreichender hitze aufweisen und damit
die grundlage überhaupt für leben
liefern leider muss man an dieser stelle
festhalten dass unsere derzeitige
satelliten und teleskopen nicht
leistungsstark genug sind um dies bis
ins letzte detail zu erforschen hoffnung
aber gibt das james webb
weltraumteleskop kurz ios das
riesenteleskop ist unter anderem jahr
speziell dafür entwickelt worden
außerirdisches leben zu suchen
anders als das hubble teleskop das im
sichtbaren nahen ultravioletten und
nahen infraroten spektrum sucht ist dass
jamie osc ein supertalent im infraroten
bereich so kann es beispielsweise die
atmosphäre und das ist der punkt die
atmosphäre von exoplaneten analysieren
das ist wirklich der absolute wahnsinn
und die wiederum kann spannende hinweise
auf platin tages leben liefern die uns
derzeit verfügbare technik steht uns
also bei der suche noch etwas im weg wie
es auch die datenmenge die analysiert
werden muss kaum zu bewältigen dazu der
israelisch russische unternehmer juri
milner
denn die private search for
extraterrestrial intelligence kurz rät
die initiative unter anderem zusammen
mit dem astrophysiker stephen hawking
initiiert hat seit menschengedenken war
die suche nach leben jenseits der erde
mit limitierten datenmengen kommt
montiert wir konnten bis dann also immer
nur spekulieren jetzt erhalten wir immer
mehr und mehr daten und wir können damit
wirkliche wissenschafts betreiben indem
wir all diese daten auch der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen kann
sich jeder der möchte an der suche nach
antworten auf die große frage beteiligen
die privat finanziert us-initiative
break kulissen hat deswegen anfang des
jahres einen riesigen lauschangriff
gestartet mit dem außerirdisches leben
endlich dingfest gemacht werden soll
es handelt sich um insgesamt 2 petabyte
raw daten gesammelt von radioteleskopen
die insgesamt drei jahre lang die
milchstraße nach möglichen funksignalen
abgehört haben die gesamten daten sind
im internet zu finden und somit kann
sich jeder von uns bei der suche nach
hinweisen auf außerirdische
kommunikation beteiligen und beim
durchforsten helfen mit dem eigenen
computer dafür gibt es spezielle
programme zudem soll die ganze suche
noch ausgeweitet werden
auch die radioteleskope des very large
array es in den usa sollen demnächst bei
der fahndung nach außerirdischen
signalen mit am start sein dazu werden
spezielle module installiert dazu der
forscher andrew sie mir dieses interface
wird es uns erlauben eine
leistungsstarke weit gefächerte seht die
durchmusterung durchzuführen die weit
vollständiger ist als alle bisherigen
suchen diese art alle kräfte werden
derzeit also gebündelt um endlich den
durchbruch bei der alien suche zu
schaffen
möglicherweise haben wir einfach noch
nicht genau genug gesucht ein us
forschungsteam hat dem vergangenen jahr
2019 ein modell gezeigt dass die
milchstraße voller bewohnter
sternensysteme sein könnte
die uns bislang noch unbekannt sind denn
in der milchstraße gibt es mindestens
100 milliarden sterne
und noch mehr planeten zehn milliarden
planeten davon könnten sogar ehrt
ähnlich sein
somit haben wir bis dann nur einen
klitzekleinen teil genau abgesucht also
es sind ein paar tausend exoplaneten die
bisher bekannt sind in ihrer simulation
ging das forschungsteam davon aus dass
fremde zivilisationen nur einige wenige
bewohnbare welten besuchen würden die
sie antreffen
trotz dieser annahme könnte sich laut
dieser studie intelligentes
außerirdisches leben bereits in der
gesamten galaxie ausgebreitet haben die
fachleute sind optimistisch dass wir
demnächst bei unserer suche erfolgreich
sein werden oder sind uns außerirdische
bereits jetzt sogar viel näher als wir
vielleicht denken
die britische ex astronauten und
chemikerin hellen chairman ist fest
davon überzeugt dass es zitat da draußen
alle möglichen arten von lebensformen
geben muss dass es sie im all gibt steht
für sie fest dazu sagt sie im guardian
interview außerirdische existieren es
gibt kein zweifel daran es gibt so viele
milliarden von sternen da draußen im
universum dass es alle möglichen arten
von lebensformen geben muss die
entscheidende frage dabei
warum haben wir sie trotz intensiver
suche bislang noch nicht aufgespürt auch
dazu hat helen german einen möglichen
erklärungsansatz es ist möglich dass sie
schon hier sind und wie sie einfach
nicht sehen können und so besteht auch
die hoffnung dass außerirdisches leben
irgendwann einmal auf unsere
kontaktversuche antwortet ein
forschungsteam des renommierten
massachusetts institute of technology em
überlegen beispielsweise mit hilfe eines
sehr starken laser scharf gebündelt ins
all zu leuchten
die größte herausforderung sei es bei
dem projekt die sonne zu überstrahlen
doch von solchen ideen wiederum sind
nicht alle fachleute überzeugt stephen
hawking jedenfalls hatte zu lebzeiten
eine ganz klare meinung er riet von
einer kontaktaufnahme mit aliens ab
seiner meinung nach könnte dies dazu
führen dass überhaupt auf uns aufmerksam
werden und uns dann zerstören naja aber
dafür müsste es auch einen grund geben
denn wenn sie bis zu uns kommen warum
sollten sie uns dann töten wie haben ja
rein gar nichts was sie brauchen könnten
denn offensichtlich ist alles was wir
haben wasser sauerstoff rohstoffe im
weltall zur genüge vorhanden ehrlich
gesagt finde ich das nicht sehr
plausibel astronautin behauptet es gibt
aliens anklicken anschauen und den
megacoolen kanal astro comics tv
abonnieren also unbedingt drauf klicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran